[Musique]
à la fin du xvième siècle une bande de
cosaques menée par un chef légendaire
yermack passent l'oral pénètre en
sibérie et en moins d'un siècle sous mes
pieds population locale cet immense
territoire de 16 millions de kilomètres
carrés n'avait pour tout richesse que
des fourrures
depuis le 20e siècle ses terres en
partie gelée ont été explorés sont des
exploités sous la neige d'immenses
réserves de matières fossiles du charbon
du pétrole et du gaz
c'est la richesse de la fédération de
russie
dans un monde en proie à une incertitude
grandissante en matière
d'approvisionnement énergétique la
russie retrouve son influence perdue à
la suite de l'effondrement de l'urss
premiers producteurs de gaz naturel la
russie détient un tiers du total des
réserves mondiales depuis 1992 une
société gazprom est chargée par l'état
russe de produire distribuer et vendre
cette source d'énergie
[Applaudissements]
gazprom n'est pas une société comme les
autres
les hommes de gazprom sont des
professionnels des marchés gaziers mais
aussi des politiques des ministres des
députés des ambassadeurs
et conseillers directe du président
vladimir poutine
tous jouent un rôle dans le nouveau jeu
énergétique mondiale
à moscou cet immeuble est aussi connu
que le kremlin
le quartier général de gazprom est aussi
un lieu de pouvoir
en 2005 la russie de vladimir poutine
est devenu actionnaire majoritaire de
l'entreprise
gasprom contrôle aujourd'hui un quart de
l'ensemble des réserves gazières
mondiales et 94 % du gaz naturel russe
mais gazprom ce n'est pas que le gaz le
géant énergétique étend son emprise par
le jeu des filiales sur les activités
pétrolières nucléaire la construction
mécanique
gazprom détient aussi des médias chaînes
de télévision radio presse mais aussi
une banque une compagnie d'aviation
[Musique]
après des mois de négociations et de
demandes répétées la direction de
gazprom a accepté de nous ouvrir ses
portes
[Musique]
nous sommes en février 2007
c'est sergueï kouprianov le porte parole
la voix de gazprom qui nous accueille
[Musique]
dans son bureau face à lui une photo le
montre au côté du numéro un de gazprom
alexeï miller un proche de vladimir
poutine dont il fut un adjoint à la
mairie de saint pétersbourg
alex müller ne s'exprime pas devant les
caméras il laisse à son porte-parole le
soin de nous expliquer pourquoi les
portes de gazprom nous sont ouvertes
effectivement depuis l'année dernière
l'intérêt pour notre compagnie s'est
brusquement accrue
je ne sais pas si la situation en
ukraine en étaient la cause ou a servi
de prétexte
nous on touche tous mais le fait que
l'on s'intéresse davantage à nous et je
pense une bonne chose
et une fois cette première vague
d'agitation passé on se souviendra de
nous la
base de notre business c'est bien sur
l'extraction le transport et la vente du
gaz
c'est à partir de cette base qui a été
fondé la compagnie et ses deux sacs
avant tout elle vit actuellement
nous sommes l'un des plus grands
producteurs de gaz dans le monde
nous en extrayons plus que toute autre
compagnie et ce depuis plusieurs
décennies
nice quelques uns des sit in et depuis
plus de 35 ans nous assurons la
fourniture du gaz à l'europe
depuis la crise avec l'ukraine durant
l'hiver 2005 2006 et la menace de
l'arrêt de la fourniture du gaz à
l'europe durant quelques jours
l'attention des médias se portent
quotidiennement sur les activités de
gazprom
nous avons rendez vous avec un homme clé
du groupe chargé spécialement des
exportations de gaz celle qui rapporte
beaucoup d'argent à gazprom et donc à la
russie
alexandre medvedev le spécialiste du
bras de fer l'homme de toutes les
négociations commerciales difficiles qui
ont fait la réputation de gazprom
cela ne nous étonne pas que l'on prête
plus d'attention aux leaders de son
domaine
ils se promettent une des plus grandes
compagnies gazières au monde est déjà
aujourd'hui la plus importante compagnie
énergétique
l'une des plus grandes au match de coupe
et notre capitalisation boursière
s'élève à plus de 250 milliards de
dollars
nos actionnaires sont russes et
étrangers oui naturellement tout le
monde s'inquiète qu'est ce que gazprom
au 6e étage du quartier général de
gazprom le centre nerveux de tout le
système de distribution de gaz pour la
russie et l'europe
30% du gaz consommé en europe est fourni
par gazprom
les lignes vertes représentent les
gazoducs et les points jaunes les
stations de compression qui propulse le
gaz dans les tuyaux
depuis cette salle gazprom contrôle plus
de cent cinquante mille kilomètres de
gazoduc sur le territoire russe
c'est ici que tout peut se jouer que
l'ordre peut être donnée de fermer le
robinet comme pendant la crise avec
l'ukraine en décembre 2005
[Musique]
nous avons réduit l'année du gaz à
l'ukraine le 1er janvier à 10 heures du
matin
et l'accord n'a été finalement signé que
le 4 janvier
nous ont suffi pour réduire la mener du
gaz au niveau qui nous a été demandé par
la direction
l'ukraine désormais l'un des pays en
conflit gazier permanent avec la russie
l'ukraine un pays par lequel transite
80% des exportations du gaz russe vers
l'europe
l'ukraine a longtemps payer son gaz
russe à un prix d'ami consenti au nom de
l'amitié entre moscou et la petite
russie mais depuis la révolution orange
en décembre 2004 l'ukraine penche à
l'ouest vers l'union européenne et les
etats unis la russie ne voit plus de
raisons de continuer à subventionner
l'ukraine en juin 2005 gazprom annonce
son intention de relever ses tarifs 2,50
à 230 dollars les mille mètres cubes six
mois plus tard le bras de fer s'engage
pourquoi donc décidé de suspendre ses
livraisons de gaz ce qui pourrait avoir
des répercussions sur des
approvisionnements en europe dont 15% du
gaz transite par le gazoduc ukrainien
kas prom l'avait promis il l'a fait la
russie ne fournit plus de gaz à
l'ukraine
bonjour la compagnie d'état russe qui
fournit le gaz a cessé ses
approvisionnements pour réduire ses
livraisons de gaz vers l'ukraine une
mesure de représailles contre les pays
qui refusent de payer plus cher leurs
gardes
alors moscou commence une autre guerre
psychologique celle ci le représentant
du géant russe gazprom accuse ici
l'ukraine ne vouloir voler le gaz
destiné aux européens
quoi qu'il en soit pas d'affolement
france en allemagne en italie les plus
gros clients mais l'union européenne se
déclare préoccupée
après trois jours de coupure de gaz de
l'ukraine les russes obtiennent
satisfaction les ukrainiens acceptent de
payer leur gaz 95 $ au lieu de 50 depuis
le tarif ne cesse d'augmenter 130
dollars en 2007 à kiev il y en
permanence un homme qui veille aux
intérêts de gazprom
victor tchernomirdine il est ambassadeur
de russie en ukraine ancien premier
ministre de boris eltsine il a été aussi
le premier président de la société
gazprom constituée en 1989
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nommé à kiev par vladimir poutine victor
tchernomirdine est passé maître dans
l'art de maintenir la pression sur les
anciens amis ukrainiens
en octobre 2007 il n'avait pas hésité à
annoncer que le prix du gaz dépendrait
du résultat des élections législatives
et de la composition du nouveau
gouvernement
deux ans auparavant il avait géré à sa
manière la crise ukrainienne
comment ça quelle crise en ukraine
quel rapport il n'y avait aucune crise
en ukraine
à les payer vous habitez ou en
angleterre non en france et en france on
vous donne du gaz sans argent ou dans un
magasin est ce que vous pouvez prendre
soin que ce soit sans argent pourquoi
ici alors on peut prendre sans payer
alors c'est toujours lors à dire payer
et vous recevrez vous ne payez pas
partie vous n'aurez rien
[Musique]
iouchtchenko son nouveau gouvernement
sont arrivés ils nous ont dit allez-y
faites le pourvoi l'avait dit en premier
dès qu'il était arrivé au poste de
président mais c'est comme ça que ça a
commencé et nous avons mis en garde mais
tenez en compte le prix va être celui du
marché alors on a prévenu une première
fois en
juillet on a prévenu de nouveaux puits
en novembre on leur a dit préparez vous
le prix va changer à partir du 1er
janvier le prix sera tout autre il ne
réagissait pas il ya moins même je les
dis en personne au président
victor andrier beach pensez-y à partir
du 1er janvier le prix va changer
va-t-on préparez-vous que tu me absence
de quoi vous en discutez pas pourquoi
personne n'est tu dis ils ont fait
traîner la chaux jusqu'au 30 décembre
voilà tout
et après le 30 décembre il s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé on a dit c'est fini
si vous ne payez pas ou ne vous fournit
pas de gaz alors ils ont commencé à
payer
c'est encore un malentendu car tous nos
contrats d'européens étaient entièrement
nus
qui plus est au moment où l'ukraine
avait sans aucune autorisation retirer
des gazoducs d'exportation un certain
volume de gaz qui était destiné aux
consommateurs européens et non pas à
elle nous avons compensé ce retrait le
lendemain même
n'avons pas fourni de gaz en ukraine
pour une seule et simple raison il n'y
avait pas de contrat trouvez moi une
seule entreprise au monde qui fournira
son produit sans contrat ça n'existe pas
en décembre 2006 l'europe a échappé de
peu à la crise biélorusse autres pays où
transite le gaz russe à destination de
l'europe aux termes de l'accord la
biélorussie paye 100 dollars les mille
mètres cubes de gaz et cède la moitié de
ses gazoducs à gazprom
crise après crise gazprom devient peu à
peu propriétaires de réseau de gazoducs
en dehors du territoire russe pour
officiellement assurer la sécurité de
l'approvisionnement de ses clients
européens
et en dictant ses prix la société trouve
de nouvelles ressources financières pour
entretenir et développer son immense
réseau
mis bout à bout les gazoducs de gazprom
pourrait faire quatre fois le tour de la
terre chaque année plus de 15000
kilomètres de gazoducs sont inspectés et
rénové pour livrer le gaz produit sur
les gisements de sibérie
[Musique]
les principaux gisements de gaz exploité
par gazprom sont situées au delà du
cercle polaire
en hiver lorsque le thermomètre descend
à moins 50 degrés le jour ne dure pas
plus de quatre heures
[Musique]
cette région au nord de la sibérie
fourni 85 % du gaz russe
[Musique]
les experts estiment que 20% des
réserves mondiales gazières sont situés
dans cette région
[Musique]
les gisements de rangueil produisent le
gaz pour le marché européen
[Musique]
ici plus de 2500 puits ont été forés
dans le sous-sol gelé dans une cuirasse
de permafrost épaisse de 400 m
[Musique]
nous nous trouvons sur un site unique le
gisement durango y source de pétrole de
gaz et de gaz condensé nous pouvons voir
ici la mise en service des puits
d'extraction des produits qui sont
situés à une profondeur de plus de 1000
mètres dans des dépôts crayeux ce
gisement est exploité depuis presque
trente ans
actuellement le volume postale
d'extraction et de 100 milliards de
mètres cubes de gaz par an
j'ai cette idée
ce site c'est la fierté de la russie
mise à part le gast on extrait du gaz
condensé et du pétrole
les perspectives de production pour le
futur daly elle s'ouvre pour des
dizaines d'années à venir et dans toute
la région
il fait très froid ici c'est vrai c'est
la particularité
évidemment les conditions de travail
sont différentes de celles du reste de
la russie sans parler de l'europe
mais l'être humain s'habitue à tout et
malgré les difficultés certains
travaillent ici depuis presque trente
ans
les gaziers qui travaillent ici ont en
moyenne 20 ans d'ancienneté
on raconte que le gaz a surgi par hasard
au début des années 60 les premiers
techniciens furent envoyés dans la
région pour chercher du pétrole les
bateaux s'étant trouvé piégé dans les
glaces de l'alena la des trois fleuves
de la région les techniciens qui étaient
à bord ont commencé à faire des forages
pour passer le temps c'est du gaz qui
est sorti de la terre
géologue et ingénieurs du komsomol les
jeunesses communistes
venus de toute l'urss prirent possession
de ces contrées déserte où de
gigantesques gisements de gaz venait
d'être localisé
à
l'époque de l'union soviétique
gazprom produisait plus de 600 milliards
de mètres cubes de gaz contre 500 de nos
jours
c'était plus précisément aux alentours
de 630 milliards mais nous étions depuis
toujours titanesque jamais nous mettions
faible
[Musique]
nous en étions conscients nous avons
voulu et avons développé gazprom dans
cette logique
ce n'est pas par hasard
nous avons sciemment conçu ce système
dès le départ ou cheo dans ce but nous
avons utilisé les meilleurs savoir-faire
du monde tout ce qui a été fait de
meilleur à l'époque nous l'avons mise en
oeuvre dans le corps du gazprom les
meilleures technologies les meilleures
découvertes scientifiques
nous avons collaboré avec toutes les
compagnies européennes et américaines
voilà pourquoi gazprom est devenu tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui
promogim c'est à coire gr sport nous
l'avions consciemment organisée nous
savions que nous avions toujours
maintenir le niveau de production élevé
pourquoi parce que nos réserves nous
permettre
nos réserves nous permettre de mettre la
barre très haut et de faire même
davantage
tichelen
une fois que le gaz est nettoyée à
sécher il passe ensuite à travers un
gazomètre vous avez dû déjà la percevoir
là bas on fait des calculs
d'exploitation du gaz à partir des
volumes extraits
de ses calculs nous obtenons des
résultats qui se chiffrent en millions
de mètres cubes de gaz et nous faisons
suivre ces données au département des
transports de gazprom
c'est transgaz qui s'occupe de
l'acheminement du gaz et de sa livraison
aux consommateurs
[Musique]
des stations de compression plus de 260
dans toute la russie se charge de faire
avancer le gaz dans les gazoducs à une
vitesse de 40 km heure
à elles seules les stations de
compression consomme presque 10% de la
production
un écart de température de 1 degré
celsius en moins peut entraîner par
exemple une consommation supplémentaire
de 40 millions de mètres cubes de gaz
soit l'équivalent de la consommation
quotidienne de gaz russe en france
[Musique]
les capacités de production de gazprom
sont colossales pourtant les experts
européens de l'énergie s'inquiètent les
gisements actuels s'épuise peu à peu la
production a baissé de 10% en dix ans
gazprom aura-t-il les moyens de répondre
au marché européen en constante
augmentation
quatre anciens gisements les gisements
essentiel arrive qu actuellement au
stade de chute d'extraction
parmi les nouveaux gisements nous avons
le site polaire qui donne déjà 100
milliards de mètres cubes celui de
bollène covo qui va produire 150
milliards celui de shtokman avec ses 22
milliards de mètres cubes de gaz rien
que dans sa première phase
et puis il ya le nouveau gisement de la
russie méridionale un projet ou par
ailleurs prendront part des entreprises
allemandes qui donnera 25 milliards
supplémentaires
avec tous ces projets nous n'avons aucun
doute quant à l'exécution de tous nos
contrats que ce soit sur les marchés
internes comme externes y compris sur
les nouveaux marchés
notamment aux chômeurs pour que dans les
5 à 7 ans qui viennent on puisse
commencer à expédier le gaz depuis un
nouveau gisement
il faut faire les investissements
nécessaires dès aujourd'hui
si nous investissons dans l'exploration
d'un gisement nous devons prendre en
compte le fait que celui ci va être coté
entièrement tout au long de son
existence et pas seulement une ou deux
années si soyez
juste chaque gisement à sa durée de vie
on l'explorent au début
ils acquièrent la puissance d'un projet
se développe mûri fonctionne à fond
pendant un certain temps
et ensuite
inévitablement il s'épuise et se ferme
[Musique]
pour trouver rapidement les gisements du
futur et savoir comment les exploiter
gazprom dispose d'un centre de recherche
plus de 1300 spécialistes chercheurs et
scientifiques qui travaillent ils sont
engagés dans une course contre la montre
car d'ici 2015 les principaux gisements
sur leur fin de vie pourrait entraîner
une chute d'un quart de la production de
gaz de gazprom
le temps des forages à l'aveuglé révolue
la modélisation en trois dimensions
permet désormais de visualiser des fils
mans accessible et les difficultés
géologiques
[Musique]
ce que nous voyons ici c'est un procédé
pour déterminer le type de roche degré
de saturation etc nous disposons ainsi
des paramètres de capacité de la roche
des coefficients pour résister il montre
combien en réalité il y adeux vite dans
la roche et combien le contient de
pétrole et de gaz
oui
romane samso nov il dirige le centre de
recherche
l'avenir de gazprom dépend en grande
partie des découvertes de son institut
nous avons reçu ce prix pour
l'élaboration du modèle géologique du
gisement de shtokman
comme on l'a souvent dit c'est un site
unique situé au fond de l'océan à 350
mètres de profondeur et à 650 km de la
côte c'est là où nos scientifiques sont
en train d'étudier ce gisement est donc
c'est pour l'élaboration de son modèle
d'extraction et de l'estimation de ses
réserves que nous avons reçu le premier
prix corporatif pour l'année 2006
il s'agit de la première édition de ce
prix nous en sommes honorés et il nous
motive pour réaliser de nouveaux
exploits
disons que d'abord tout commence par la
prospection les travaux de recherche sur
les nouveaux sites
la prospection des gisements la
recherche géologiques sont des métiers
d'exception
les géologues sont comme des magiciens
qui sont capables de trouver au fond de
la terre des ressources utilisables
les sources
grâce au travail de nos géologues de nos
chercheurs
grâce aux technologies modernes de
conception des modèles en trois
dimensions
nous avons pu déterminer les réserves du
gisement de shtokman
source
la capacité du site de shtokman a été
estimée à 3,7 trillions de mètres cubes
6017 donc pratiquement à 4 trillions de
mètres cubes de gaz qui seront
accessibles
il chauffe peu idiot nosca que google au
swing elle est source vient ensuite la
prospection de la baie james dyson
ainsi l'exploration de ces grands sites
permet de programmer les livraisons de
gaz en grande quantité à long terme pas
seulement à court terme
[Musique]
le gigantesque gisement de shtokman
n'est pas encore exploité en raison des
conditions d'extraction arctique et de
sa profondeur en attendant pour
augmenter sa production gazprom peut
compter parfois sur de reuze coïncidence
sakhaline à l'extrémité de la sibérie
sur les rives de l'océan pacifique
l'île recèle d'importantes ressources
naturelles en hydrocarbures pétrole et
gaz dans les années 90 lorsque boris
elstine vendait les richesses d'un pays
pratiquement en faillite les compagnies
étrangères ont obtenu des licences
d'exploitation à des conditions
extrêmement avantageuses mais en 2006
les compagnies gazières étrangères
néerlandaises et japonaises ont
rencontré à sakhaline un sérieux
problème lorsqu'elles ont commencé les
travaux
oleg mitvol vice directeur des services
russes de surveillance des ressources
naturelles un écologiste dans l'âme mais
aussi un patriote qui ne fait aucun
cadeau aux compagnies étrangères
implantées en russie
[Musique]
ils ont arrêté le travail sur le tuyau
depuis le 18 août maintenant il ne
travaille plus ils font du lobbying
politique afin de faire reconnaître ce
travail comme un bon travail et remplir
enfin ce tuyau avec du pétrole et quand
cette femme va glisser en bas avec le
tuyau chargés de pétrole on aura une
grave catastrophe écologique qui va
atteindre la mer
voyez un tuba
et bien c'est un câble en fibre optique
qui signale les avaries sur l'oléoduc
il est bien sûr déjà hors service
pleindoux et il flotte là sur la surface
comme un élément de décoration
voilà quel travail ces gens
regardez par vous même
en 2006 pendant des mois la compagnie
néerlandaise shell et de compagnies
japonaises rassembler dans une société
d'exploitation baptisé sakhaline-2 ont
dû répondre aux questions des
fonctionnaires d'un organisme d'état
leur esprit road nador chargé des
enquêtes écologique menée par oleg
mitvol
lors de son déplacement sur l'île de
sakhaline ses services ont dressé plus
de 100 constat de violations aux
règlements environnementaux
et pour être sûr que ça se sache ses
services ont filmé toute la mission
tout d'abord nous ne sommes pas des
shérifs nous sommes des inspecteurs et
nous avons le droit de contrôler si le
contrat de licence est véritablement
respecter nous avons droit de vérifier
comment les compagnies respectent les
normes écologiques réussite cette fois
au talent au statut
dans la constitution russe l'article de
42 et dicte le droit des citoyens à
disposer d'un environnement sain
tout ce que l'on fait nous le faisons en
concertation avec des ong écologistes
cette bataille de la communication avec
la compagnie shell nous l'avons gagnée
uniquement grâce à notre mode de
procéder afin de répondre à toutes les
requêtes nous avons invité tout le monde
à venir sur sakhaline et tous se
terminer comme ça
curieusement le contexte était celui ci
d'un côté il y avait une compagnie
immense transnationales qui de l'argent
du pétrole vendu déjà exporté de la
russie l'expérience internationale
l'influencent sur les premiers ministres
de différents pays des centaines de
juristes et de l'autre il n'y avait que
quelques fonctionnaires
ezio dans le bras de fer entre oleg
mitvol et les compagnies étrangères
toutes les discussions n'ont pas porté
que sur les règlements environnementaux
permettait la situation est la suivante
tout cet argent appartient à la
fédération de russie ses eaux
territoriales appartiennent à la
fédération de russie hélas une compagnie
étrangère arrive et nous explique ce que
nous devons faire et on ouvre on allait
en quelques jours oleg mitvol a remporté
la guerre des images contre la compagnie
néerlandaise shell et les compagnies
japonaises
[Musique]
fait voir s'il vous plaît c'est pour la
caméra
voilà les étoiles de mer sont devenus
comme ça maintenant si on peut encore
appeler ça une étoile
[Musique]
regardez il ya aussi des coquillages
comme celui là avant ils poussaient sur
de gros rochers il était multicolores et
très beau maintenant voilà ce qu'on a
mais pourquoi c'est comme ça
je pense que suite aux travaux
d'ingénierie
on a jeté dans les rivières qui se
trouvent dans la zone de lusine de
grandes quantités de vase et de terre
[Musique]
beaucoup de terres de la boue oui de la
boue
je vous dire une chose malheureusement
nombre de fonctionnaires russes de façon
incompréhensible pour moi prennent le
parti de la compagnie shell je ne sais
pas comment appeler ça mais j'aimerais
savoir pourquoi shell a tant de fans
dans l'administration de russie il
savait châble et c'est une réalité
vidéo c'est parce que les médias était à
mes côtés ainsi que les organismes
internationaux écologistes comme
greenpeace wwf alpha et c'est que j'ai
réussi à expliquer que les problèmes
écologiques existent vraiment et qu'il
est grand temps de s'en occuper
quel que soit l'actionnaire actuel il
faut bien comprendre que nous avons
signalé tous les problèmes qui existent
gazprom lui aussi va les traiter en
premier lieu c'est une évidence
je sais qu'une décision a été prise au
conseil d'administration de gazprom qui
a considéré comme prioritaire la
question du rétablissement de la
situation écologique
menacés de perdre leur licence
d'exploitation les compagnies étrangères
ont préféré aimablement céder la
majorité de sakhaline 2 à gazprom
ce tour de passe passe a permis au géant
russe de récupérer des licences et
d'augmenter son volume de production à
peu de frais
la guerre de sakhaline a été un
révélateur à la fois de la puissance de
gazprom mais aussi de ses faiblesses
pour maintenir et accroître son niveau
de production dans les prochaines années
experts et investisseurs étrangers sont
inquiets l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie agence autonome de l' ocde a
son siège à paris
sa première mission est de s'assurer de
la sécurité des approvisionnements
énergétiques des 26 pays membres avec le
fournisseur gazprom tous les doutes ne
sont pas levés
claude mandil directeur exécutif de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie ce
qui préoccupe les clients de gazprom et
ce qui préoccupe une agence comme la
mienne qui est une agence comme vous
l'avez rappelé composé d'experts dans le
domaine énergétique
c'est que nous avons l'impression que
pour l'instant de gasprom n'investit pas
assez dans le développement de nouveaux
champs gaziers il faut bien comprendre
le problème car une fois n'est pas
savoir s'il ya du psylle gaz existe
toujours nous sommes sûrs qu'il existe
massivement mais
pour qu'il soit disponible dans les
tuyaux il faut faire des investissements
très importants qu'on appelle un
investissement de développement il faut
forer des puits il faut construire des
usines de traitement il faut
développer il faut faire de la recherche
pour savoir exactement où sont les
nouveaux gisements et tout ça prend
beaucoup d'argent et nous n'avons pas
l'impression qu'au cours des dernières
années
gazprom et dépensez suffisamment
d'argent dans ce domaine par conséquent
les gisements actuels s'épuisent et les
gisements nouveau ne sont pas prêts en
tout cas autant qu'il le faudrait
j'avais proposé aux directeurs des
agences de licencier leurs analystes
pour cause de qualifications
insuffisante mais je ne sais pas si mes
recommandations ont été entendus notre
plan de production de gaz est
entièrement élaborée pour les 20 ans à
venir doivent prenant en compte les
nouveaux marchés
nous savons combien nous devons investir
pour réaliser nos projets nous
intervenons dans ce business depuis
longtemps et savons comment l'organiser
à l'époque soviétique ont planifié les
niveaux de production tous les ans pour
chaque période quinquennale
maintenant le principe est temps que le
gaz n'est pas vendu il ne sera pas
produit
étant une entreprise commerciale nous
partons de ce principe de base nous
tiendrons toujours nos engagements et
produiront autant de gaz que c'est prévu
par tel ou tel contrat
je préférerais qu'on puisse s'asseoir
autour d'une table pour discuter chacun
de nos chiffres des leurs voir qui a
raison qui a tort pour l'instant ça ne
nous est pas possible
encore une fois
nos critiques sont très
focalisés nous ne mettons pas en cause
le fait que jusqu'ici gazprom a été un
fournisseur de très grande qualité et ne
mettons pas en cause le fait que les
réserves sont extrêmement importantes
nous mettons en cause l'insuffisance de
l'investissement
et en plus nous disons ce qui est
dommage c'est qu'il y aurait des moyens
simples pour augmenter massivement la
quantité des dieux de gaz disponible
pour l'exportation
nos investissements représentent pour
cette année 20 milliards de dollars pour
l'année prochaine ce sera 22 dans un
encore 26
nous avons planifié où nous mettrons
l'argent pour pouvoir extraire le gaz le
pétrole et les autres ressources pour
transporter nos produits et les vendre à
nos consommateurs producteurs
nous veillons à ce que nos consommateurs
soient contents car nous ne produisons
pas pour faire état d'achèvement le
volume de production mais bel et bien
pour satisfaire nos clients
gasprom me répond mais non nous
investissons beaucoup alors c'est vrai
ils investissent beaucoup mais
investissent beaucoup dans l'électricité
dans
les médias dans la construction d'un
nouveau siège
dans le rachat d'autres entreprises mais
ça ne fait pas un mètre cube de gaz de
plus c'était du gaz qui était produit
par d'autres et qui est produit par
gazprom donc tout ça ce n'est pas des
investissements dans le développement de
nouveaux gisements c'est ça notre
préoccupation
selon les experts européens pour
satisfaire la demande croissante de
l'europe les exportations de gaz russe
devrait augmenter de 100 milliards de
mètres cubes d'ici 2015 mais dans la
même période la production des
principaux gisements sur leur fin de vie
pourrait reculer de 150 milliards de
mètres cubes dans ces conditions comment
gazprom pourra-t-il remplir ses
engagements
cette question empoisonne les relations
commerciales entre gazprom et ses
clients une crise de confiance alors que
70% des bénéfices de gazprom proviennent
des exportations de gaz vers l'union
européenne
beaucoup plus cool que quand on sait
précisément combien de matières
premières on doit produire
[Musique]
et dès que l'on a des garanties sur ce
du fait que ce gaz sera achetée selon la
tarification du marché de ressources
énergétiques au moment donné
on peut alors sans problème investir
dans l'exploration de nouveaux gisements
les maîtriser puis extraire et expédié
le gaz
c'est le principe selon lequel nous
travaillons de gris tout ces dernières
années
la construction du système de gazoduc
relie les gisements de la sibérie
occidentale avec les consommateurs en
europe avait également nécessiter des
investissements colossaux qui étaient
impossibles à aborder sans avoir des
garanties sur de nos ventes de gaz
vous savez l'histoire de nos relations
avec l'europe évolue déjà depuis 40 ans
dans un sens positif
c'est peut-être la crise de la
quarantaine qui arrive mais je suis sûr
qu'elle sera surmontée et la
collaboration dans le domaine du gaz
entre la russie et l'europe va
s'accroître car il s'agit de relations
d'interdépendance
nous dépendons de l'europe aussi bien
que l'europe dépend de nous
nous ainsi que nos partenaires les
compagnies avec lesquelles nous
travaillons depuis 35 à 40 ans nous
sommes certains que ce partenariat va se
développer et que l'europe restera le
marché principal pour le gaz russe
indépendamment de la volonté des
journalistes le rôle du gaz russe en
europe va grandir
actuellement le gaz russe représente 26
% du marché européen en 2010 2015 ce
sera à 33% c'est une réalité objective
is you
je crois que c'est plutôt bien pour
l'europe car sa compétitivité dépend
pour beaucoup du gaz naturel russe
pour l'état russe actionnaire
majoritaire de gazprom la société doit
donc rassurer ses clients pour maintenir
son influence est celle de la russie sur
le marché énergétique mondial
le gouvernement a trouvé une solution
radicale
réduire la consommation de gaz des
russes pour assurer l'approvisionnement
des européens
actuellement les deux tiers de la
production du gaz russes partent pour la
consommation intérieure les centrales
électriques fonctionnent au gaz à elle
seule elle consomme 37 % du gaz produit
en russie et pour les russes le gaz est
cinq fois moins cher que pour les
européens
résultat les prix peu élevés n'incite
pas les particuliers et les entreprises
à réduire leur consommation bien au
contraire
en novembre 2006 le gouvernement russe a
donc décidé une hausse de 15% par an du
prix du gaz sur le marché intérieur
vous savez c'est une chose qui peut
paraître étonnante nous ne décidons pas
du prix du gaz ni sur le marché interne
ni sur le marché externe
sur le marché interne c'est le
gouvernement qui fixe le prix des
livraisons et ce prix est variable honte
honte que cette chose près il n'y a pas
longtemps une petite partie du marché
devenu libre ce qui nous donne la
possibilité de vendre le gaz à la bourse
où le prix est établi en fonction de
l'offre et de la demande au cours des
négociations boursière
de même sur les marchés européens ce
n'est pas nous qui fixons le prix car
nous travaillons sur la base des
contrats à long terme le prix est réglée
en fonction des marchés des produits
pétroliers via les mécanismes de la
bourse
en 2012 les russes paieront leur gaz
pratiquement au même prix que les
européens
conséquence prévisible ils vont
drastiquement réduire leur consommation
de gaz ce qui va permettre à gazprom de
disposer de nouveaux volumes de
production pour l'exportation vers
l'europe
cette restructuration du marché gazier
intérieures russes au bénéfice de
gazprom et de la russie sur la scène
internationale pourrait entraîner une
grave crise économique et sociale
pour certains la russie a basculé dans
une économie de guerre
sergey glazunov candidat à l'élection
présidentielle en 2004 contre vladimir
poutine économiste réputé aujourd'hui
député de l'opposition il se présente
comme un patriote de gauche
[Musique]
oh
gazprom a pris la décision de faire
augmenter le prix du gaz sur le marché
interne et oblige les entreprises russes
à passer au prix quasi libre de fait
issu d'un monopole de la la russie perd
son avantage stratégique
à savoir les ressources énergétiques ce
cher sans cet avantage nous risquons de
perdre notre modèle économique
pourquoi parce que nous devons prendre
en compte la consommation énergétique
inhérentes aux modes de production dans
notre pays plus sûr pour quoi que l'on
fasse notre production restera toujours
deux fois plus consommatrices d'énergie
qu'en europe nous allons donc perdre un
l'industrie métallurgique l'industrie
chimique la majeure partie des
constructions mécaniques qui à l'échelle
des prix du marché international du gaz
ne seront plus compétitive
actuellement toute la politique du
pouvoir est organisée en faveur des
intérêts commerciaux des structures
privilégié bien connue est celle qui a
joué le plus c'est gazprom
[Musique]
oh
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il faut essayer de faire en sorte que
gazprom n'abuse plus de son statut de
monopole sur le marché s'il n'augmente
pas le prix pour le gaz qu'ils se
chargent de l'accomplissement scrupules
au dos de ses engagements
actuellement on a un décalage un gazprom
s'efforce d'exporter le plus de casse
possible car le prix l'exportation quand
on se casse fois plus avantageux que le
prix sur le marché interne par
conséquent il limite la consommation du
gaz à l'échelle nationale
[Musique]
ans
nous profitons moins de notre richesse
énergétique puisque la majeure partie du
pétrole est presque la moitié du gaz
partent à l'étranger
et le peuple russes n'en profite pas car
les bénéfices des exportations du
pétrole et du gaz sont partagés entre
les oligarques qui détiennent le
contrôle et le fonds de réserve qui
n'opèrent pas bhl à l'intérieur du pays
[Musique]
plus que jamais le secteur des
hydrocarbures prend une place
prépondérante dans l'économie de la
russie la production de gaz et de
pétrole comptent pour plus de 25 % du
pib et assure plus de 40% des recettes
du budget de l'état l'exportation
fournit environ les deux tiers des
recettes en devises du pays
l'état russe majoritaire à un peu plus
de 50% de gazprom a fait de son géant
gazier un acteur incontournable pour
l'équilibré des finances publiques
gazprom est donc sous contrôle étroit du
pouvoir à la douma le parlement russe le
président de la commission énergie est
un député du parti russie unie de
vladimir poutine
on dit aussi que valérie asaf est
officieusement le lobbyiste en chef de
gazprom
il est évident pour tout le monde que
durant la perestroïka et ensuite dans
les années 90 des années très difficiles
c'est gazprom et lui seul qui a maintenu
le pays à flot et qu'il a littéralement
sauvé du froid
valérie acef connaît tous les rouages de
gazprom et avec lui toutes les portes
s'ouvrent
il nous invite à assister à l'une des
réunions de la commission énergie de la
douma qui se tient dans la grande salle
du conseil de la tour gazprom
en russie valérie acef est décrit comme
l'une des personnes les mieux informés
du marché gazier
il est aussi connu pour dire
publiquement et souvent brutalement ce
que ni gazprom ni l'état russe ne peut
annoncer directement à ses clients ou
aux pays européens
valérie est c'est fait donc le
porte-voix officieux du conseil
d'administration de gazprom un conseil
d'administration très politique pour une
société souvent décrite comme un état
dans l'état
les conseils des directeurs de gazprom
et de renaître se compose
majoritairement des ministres du
gouvernement et du personnel de
l'administration du président qui
agissent selon les directives du premier
ministre
tous les grands projets toutes les
décisions importantes sont approuvées
par le conseil des directeurs c'est à
dire par le gouvernement
devant la commission de la douma et
notre caméra valeri goloubev directeur
du département des investissements
présente un tableau convenu et rassurant
des activités de gastro
ces cinq dernières années gazprom a
incontestablement augmenter le volume de
la production
selon les données de l'année 2006
gazprom avait produit 552 milliards de
mètres cubes ce qui fait de nous le plus
grand producteur de gaz au monde
le concurrent direct exxon mobil
n'extrait que 110 milliards de mètres
cubes ce qui confirme le fait que
gazprom est une entreprise puissante
quelques nouveaux marchés ont été
approchées notamment avec des pays comme
la chine la corée la grande bretagne
si on parle de l'exportation du gaz
notons qu en outre de l'expédition du
gaz via les gazoducs des premières
tentatives expérimental de liquéfaction
du gaz ont eu lieu
nous avons le droit de demander des
renseignements supplémentaires sur les
questions qui ont particulièrement
attiré notre attention la chambre des
comptes à gazprom au ministère de
l'industrie énergétique au ministère des
finances et aux services des impôts
si gazprom est sous contrôle étroit
c'est aussi parce que c'est presque une
arme une force de dissuasion autant
qu'un moyen de pression que la russie
est seule à posséder
les ressources énergétiques c'est le
sujet principal il n'y en aura pas assez
pour assurer le développement de tous
les pays ces ressources seront toujours
au centre des débats et que nous en
garde la cause d'une guerre comme celle
qui se passe en irak ou en iran
derrière tout ça moi je vois la lutte
pour les ressources énergétiques
il nous faut absolument trouver des
mécanismes internationaux pour éviter la
guerre et laisser la place à un climat
paisible de pourparlers
croyez moi une lutte pour les ressources
énergétiques est en train de se produire
dans cette lutte souvent secrètes et
diplomatique la russie conserve toujours
une longueur d'avancé
pour autant la résistance s'organise en
europe
depuis trois ans la lutte d'influencé
entre les russes et les européens se
joue dans le caucase
autour de la mer caspienne les anciennes
républiques soviétiques aujourd'hui
indépendante sont des producteurs de gaz
très importante on estime qu'elles
détiennent 10 % des réserves mondiales
de gaz
actuellement ces pays dépendent presque
totalement des gazoducs de gazprom pour
écouler leur production vers la russie
et l'europe pour conserver cet avantage
stratégique tout en évitant de devoir
faire passer le gaz du caucase par
l'ukraine pays jugés peu fiables par les
russes gazprom a décidé de se lancer
dans des travaux titanesques la
construction d'un gazoduc sous marin
ce gazoduc partirait de la russie
passerait sous la mer noire pour
atteindre la turquie avant de rejoindre
l'europe par des gazoducs terrestres
le projet s'appuie sur le savoir-faire
russe en 2002 déjà un gazoduc sous marin
acheminant du gaz russe en turquie est
entré en activité d'une longueur de 1200
13km blue stream 1 passe sous la mer
noire sur une distance de 400 km à une
profondeur atteignant plus de 2100
mètres par endroits ce qui en fait le
plus profond gazoduc au monde
[Musique]
le projet blue stream-2 est déjà à
l'étude
et des discussions sont engagées avec
les pays que le gazoduc traversera
pour contrer ce projet qui va accroître
la puissance de gazprom les européens se
tournent vers l'azerbaïdjan et la
géorgie
dans ces pays en froid avec le voisin
russe un nouveau tronçon de gazoduc
construit par un consortium soutenu par
les états unis vient d'entrer en service
le scp relie les gisements gaziers
pétroliers des badges ans à la turquie
la géorgie est la première bénéficiaire
du passage du scp le savent qu'à kazan
'pipeline' sur son territoire désormais
elle ne dépend plus du gaz russe et des
prix fixés par gazprom
la construction du scp sur le territoire
géorgien a été ressentie comme une
provocation par la russie de vladimir
poutine qui considère désormais que la
géorgie ancienne république soviétique a
basculé dans le camp de l'otan
officiellement c'est la situation en
abkhazie région séparatiste de géorgie
soutenu par moscou depuis 1993 qui est à
l'origine du contentieux entre les deux
pays
mais pour tous les observateurs la mise
en service du nouveau gazoduc fin 2006
expliquerait le regain de tension
voici l'une des bandes du pipeline qui
indique l'endroit où ils traversent la
route
pouvait voir une autre borne de l'autre
côté de la route ce qui indique la
direction que prend le gazoduc au saut
c'est assez évident est visible que le
'pipeline' va du haut de la colline face
ici juste en dessous de la borne et va
vers la rivière là bas
le s&p a coûté quatre milliards et demi
de dollars
il a été financé en grande partie par la
banque mondiale et par la banque
européenne et a été construit par un
consortium dominé par la compagnie
britannique british petroleum
nous sommes les opérateurs détroit
'pipeline' géorgie le bas coût ce spa
'pipeline' qui s'étend de bakou jusqu'au
port de ce ce parc sur la côte de la mer
noire le bakou tbilissi ceyhan qui
débouche sur la méditerranée en turquie
et ensuite le sens caucasian gas
pipeline
donc il y a trois différents consortiums
dans lesquelles il ya différents
partenaires mais dont nous sommes
l'opérateur principal
avec le sol stockage yann 'pipeline'
nous amenons le gaz en géorgie qu est ce
qui donne à l'état la possibilité de
diversifier ses ressources
d'approvisionnement par rapport à la
russie par exemple
n'importe quel autre fournisseur à
particulier ce n'est qu'une source
additionnelle qui s'ajoutent aux
le sujet est très sensible
depuis la mise en service du scp la
géorgie est au bord de la guerre avec la
russie depuis novembre 2006 les
frontières sont fermées le blocus est
complet les incidents régulier le 6 août
2007 un missile russe a même été tirés
sur le territoire géorgien
david bakradzé ministre d'état chargé de
la résolution des conflits
[Musique]
les relations qui déjà
traditionnellement ne se caractériser
par l'amabilité et bien on peut dire qu
elles se sont malheureusement fortement
détériorées
je dis malheureusement parce que la
géorgie n'a aucun intérêt à entretenir
des relations distantes est
problématique avec la russie ce qui
éteint est important un voisin important
notre intérêt c'est de régulariser ses
relations de rétablir des relations
normales
mais il n'est pas possible d'établir des
relations normales si on ne respecte pas
des principes élémentaires tels que le
bon voisinage la souveraineté et la
continuité territoriale
ce sont des principes qui sont pour nous
un incontournable
je le répète nous sommes un petit pays
et nous n'avons aucun intérêt à voir des
mauvaises relations avec la russie
david bakradze est ancien président de
la commission du parlement géorgien pour
l'intégration européenne
pour lui la situation que vit
actuellement son pays n'a pas que des
désavantages ont ce qui concerne des
enjeux économiques il ya un embargo
total qui est toujours actif un embargo
imposé par la russie qui a fermé
complètement son marché à tous les
produits fabriqués en géorgie du prado
ce n'était pas notre choix mais je crois
que lorsqu'on considère les perspectives
à long terme nous pouvons remercier la
russie pour cette décision car elle a
obligé le business géorgien à s'orienter
plus activement vers le marché européen
et vers l'union européenne
sur le long terme c'est positif pour
nous
la géorgie l'azerbaïdjan nouveaux alliés
de l'europe et avec le staff catalan
bahreïn qui rejoint la turquie une
occasion unique pour les européens
d'imaginer une solution pour contrer le
projet blue stream de gazprom c'est le
projet nabucco un gazoduc dans le
prolongement du scp permettrait de
rejoindre l'europe via la turquie en
ouvrant de nouvelles routes
d'approvisionnement par exemple vers le
turkménistan en traversant la mer
caspienne nabucco des européens blue
stream des russes un seul des deux
projets devraient voir le jour car pour
les experts du marché gazier il n'y a
pas assez d'argent disponible pour
financer les deux projets qui coûtent
chacun environ 5 milliards d'euros
désigné en mars 2007 au conseil européen
comme un projet prioritaire
le projet nabucco a été relancé en
septembre 2007 dans l'urgence entre
temps la russie et gazprom avait conclu
pendant l'été des accords d'exclusivité
d'approvisionnement gazier avec le
turkménistan et le kazakhstan
ferran tarradellas ce porte parole à la
commission européenne pour les questions
énergétiques il maîtrise parfaitement le
langage diplomatique à nous sommes très
contents nous croyons que c'est un
privilège de l'union européenne d'avoir
à la porte le principal fournisseur de
gaz du monde sas et infortunes nous
voulons travailler avec la russie et je
crois qu'il est aussi beaucoup d'intérêt
travailler aussi avec nous mais ça ne
veut pas dire que nous voulons
travailler sur le monde avec la russie
nabucco donnera l'opportunité aux pays
producteurs de gaz de vendre de gaz
d'électrons europe 1 essai nous croyons
que c'est très important beaucoup peut
être fournie aussi avec des gas libyenne
eaux égyptiennes à travers d'un nouveau
récit doute que sera construit à travers
de la côte occidentale
méditerranéenne équipe est fournie à
l'issue de deux
nouveaux courts on espère que les
situations à iraq iran and pay améliorer
la façon que nous avons des relations
amicales avec ceux des pays qu'ils ont
dans les problèmes maintenant qui
pourrait certainement il en a les
deuxièmes réserves mondiales de gaz si
les conditions géostratégique le permet
pourquoi pas apporté de gaz dira c'est
qu'on veut faire c'est augmenter la
diversification de l'approvisionnement
de marché pour permettre qu'il y ait de
la concurrence mais c'est pas injuste
contre à ce plan c'est injuste pour le
marché intérieur de l'énergie en europe
gazprom est pourtant dans toutes les
terres
19 septembre 2007 ce jour là la
commission européenne présente le projet
de libéralisation du marché de l'énergie
parmi les propositions la séparation des
activités de transport et de production
de l'énergie par les acteurs européens
du marché le marché doit s'ouvrir mais
pas à gazprom la commission a donc dû
trouver la parade
pour protéger l'intérêt que présente la
séparation des activités de transport et
de production nous devons mettre en
place des conditions drastiques sur la
possibilité par des compagnies non
européennes de posséder les
infrastructures de transport c'est très
important nous devons tous avoir les
mêmes règles ce que nous avons proposé
c'est de renforcer le marché intérieur
européen qu'il soit ouvert tout en étant
sûr que nous conserverons le plein
contrôle sur ce marché pour éviter par
exemple que des états membres prennent
des mesures particulières qui à terme
provoquerait l'éclatement de notre
marché intérieur
alors que nous voulons ouvrir le marché
que nous voulons un marché ouvert
je vais être franc avec vous nous ne
devons pas être naïfs rives
il s'agit de netteté il s'agit de
maintenir une compétition honnête la
compétition ça n'a rien à voir avec le
protectionnisme
mais si vous voulez être sûr d'avoir une
compétition loyale nous devons aussi
protéger notre marché intérieur de
comportements déloyaux qui pourrait
venir de l'extérieur
j'ai une question sur gazprom efficace
et gazprom c'est par ses activités de
transport et de production peut-il
acheter ce qu'ils contrôlaient avec plus
de 51% des actions l'une des compagnies
de transports malgache d'un état de
l'union européenne ou d'ailleurs de
plusieurs états de l'union européenne
il n'y a qu'une condition c'est qu'il y
ait séparation des activités dans deux
sociétés distinctes c'est un peu
difficile à imaginer mais en théorie
c'est possible et toujours est il que
pour détenir un réseau de distribution
cette société aurait besoin en plus d'un
accord particulier un accord bipartite
entre l'union européenne et la russie
qui autoriserait ce genre de coopération
la séparation des activités est donc
nécessaire mais suffit pas
quelques heures après cette annonce
gazprom directement visée publié un
communiqué laconique son porte parole
sergueï kouprianov déclarait gazprom à
une importante contribution à faire dans
le débat sur la régulation du secteur
énergétique en europe et est certain que
sa voix sera entendue
face à l'union européenne gazprom reste
confiant et pour cause
depuis 2005 un projet de gazoduc divise
les états membres au nord de l'europe
saint pétersbourg la ville d'origine de
vladimir poutine est aussi la ville où
sera construit d'ici 2016 le futur siège
social de gazprom
baptisé gazprom city une tour de 300
mètres de haut s'élèvera sur
l'embouchure de la neva tout près du
centre historique
saint petersbourg la ville des tsars
fondée en 1703 soupire legrand sera
bientôt la capitale de gazprom et du gaz
russe
d'autant plus qu'à quelques centaines de
kilomètres plus au nord sur les rives de
la mer baltique commencent les travaux
d'un des projets phares du géant gazier
la construction du gazoduc north stream
[Musique]
un gazoduc sous marin de plus de 1200 km
qui reliera directement la russie à
l'allemagne en passant sous la mer
baltique
détenue à 51% par gazprom et à 49% par
des sociétés allemandes le projet north
stream créé des tensions entre
l'allemagne et les états de l'est de
l'europe
pour gazprom le gazoduc sous-marin north
stream ne présente que des avantages
contrairement aux gazoducs terrestres
déjà en activité il évite de passer sur
des territoires réputé peu fiable comme
la biélorussie ensuite il évite de payer
un droit de passage à des pays désormais
ancré dans le camp occidental comme la
pologne enfin il évite les pays baltes
très critique vis-à-vis de moscou au
sein de l'union européenne
depuis deux ans ces mêmes pays baltes
font tout pour entraver le projet north
stream
[Musique]
au sein des pays du nord de l'union
européenne l'allemagne est dénoncée pour
faire cavalier seul à berlin on préfère
parler de logique et de partenariat
économique d'un côté l'allemagne réalise
vers la russie près du tiers du total
des exportations européennes
de l'autre l'allemagne importe de russie
la majeure partie de son énergie 40% du
gaz et 30% du pétrole
joachim vers mailing et secrétaire
d'état au ministère fédéral de
l'économie de la technologie
il tient le discours officiel malgré les
apparences north stream est aussi un
projet européen
[Musique]
ce n'est pas seulement du gaz pour
l'allemagne c'est du gaz pour les
pays-bas cause pour peut-être pour la
grande bretagne pour la république
tchèque
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est un
projet européen dans un intérêt européen
et c'est ce que doivent encore
comprendre beaucoup de ceux qui sont
opposés
9 septembre 2005 gerhard schröder
accueil vladimir poutine pour la
signature du projet north stream l'a dit
mi-août in par l'allemand un an paravent
gerhard schröder avait adopté une
orpheline à saint pétersbourg la ville
du président russe sans l'amitié qui lie
les deux hommes nordstream n'aurait
peut-être pas vu le jour
ce n'est dirigé contre personne feignies
contre les états baltes ni contre la
pologne
mais on doit pourtant comprendre que le
chancelier allemand et le défenseur des
intérêts énergétiques allemands
l'allemagne assure en partenariat direct
avec la russie une grande part de sa
fourniture en énergie pour des décennies
j'ai tout de même fait en sorte par de
longs entretiens avec le président qui a
été heureusement ouvert
d'avoir mis en place le contexte pour
que cette forme de coopération soit
possible
quelques mois plus tard gerhard schröder
perd les élections mais retrouve
rapidement un nouveau travail il est
nommé président du conseil de
surveillance du consortium russo
allemand chargé de la construction de
north stream
on a parlé de germano soviétique à
l'époque
c'est exactement le malentendu qui a
perduré
c'est aussi un projet entre des
entreprises et pas entre des états
il ya gazprom d'un côté et un
importateur de gaz allemand de l'autre
il n'a jamais été question que la
pologne où les états baltes soit mise à
l'écart
face à l'hégémonie de gazprom les états
membres de l'union ne parvienne pas à
tenir un discours cohérent le projet
north stream divise aujourd'hui l'europe
il en révèle aussi ses faiblesses
c'était à prouver pour le conseil
européenne l'année 2005 y compris tous
les pays de l'union européenne y compris
la pologne y compris les républiques
baltes il n'avait pas de problème
là-dessus en reconnaissant de cette
ligne comme aline prioritaire évidemment
ces investisseurs privés de mettre
l'argent dans la rue qu'il considère le
mieux ce que c'est que la commission
avait identifiées étaient des routes
possibles en dédoublement de la route
gamal actuel pour la construction d'un
gazoduc sous la mer baltique évidemment
à là où la commission va pas transiger
c'est dans les questions
environnementaux si cette info se doit
être construite il doit être construite
d'année plein respect des règles
environnementales
mais c'est aux investisseurs de faire
des maîtres l'argent de la firme
infrastructures là je crois
qu'effectivement il est des intérêts
nationaux dans l'union européenne c'est
un chose bien connu mais je crois que au
moment qu'on parle de développement de
ruth la sécurité et professionnellement
la corte énormément fait dans tous les
états membres dans le conseil européen
tous les six mois pour aplanir les
difficultés et définir un modèle de
coopération la russie et l'europe se
rencontrent pour un sommet est souvent
les européens arrivent en ordre dispersé
18 mai 2007 à samara en russie sur les
bords de la volga ce sommet va
rapidement tourné au dialogue de sourds
entre l'europe et la russie les
discussions sont tendues notamment sur
les questions énergétiques
la commission européenne défend l'idée
de solidarité des états membres son
principe si un accord de coopération
avec la russie met en difficulté un seul
état membre cela met de fait en
difficulté toute la communauté
européenne pour vladimir poutine ce
discours de solidarité est inaudible
depuis que l'europe s'est élargi à 27 et
que la pologne ravive des tensions
historiques avec la russie tout le long
du sommet vladimir poutine est
accompagné d'un de ses plus proches
conseillers sergei yastrzemski
ancien porte-parole spécial du kremlin
sur la tchétchénie il est aujourd'hui le
conseiller spécial du président pour
l'europe
[Musique]
le grand bureau des sommets c'est
avoir une scène
pour parler ouvertement
de nos relations en général
d'analysé en commun les confond les
problèmes les questions à samara la
présidence de l'union européenne était
alors allemand en principe c'est un
atout mais angela merkel n'est pas
parvenu à faire aboutir les négociations
pour un nouvel accord de partenariat qui
devait entrer en vigueur en septembre
c'est la pologne qui a mis son veto pour
manifester contre l'embargo russe sur
les importations de viande polonaise
mais aussi par crainte qu'un accord de
coopération de grande ampleur se fasse
au détriment de sa sécurité énergétique
[Musique]
et la russie aujourd'hui je pense
parfois pour nous c'est très difficile à
comprendre c'est la manque de
la manque de la créativité la manque de
la liberté ii pour les compromis
parce que le mécanisme de la prise de
décision au sein de l'union européenne
est tellement difficile tellement
bureaucratisé que une fois prise la
décision devient une dogme parfois les
gens dit non
on voit imposer notre volonté c'est la
volonté de 20,7 et il n'y a pas d'autres
variantes pour vous les russes que à
accepter
notre position
avec nous ça ne marche pas cette langue
ce langage mais les ne sont pas ne pas
nommer les pays avec lesquels on peut
parler d'eux
de la manière suivante avec nous ça ne
marche pas alors on dira vous n'êtes pas
intéressé vous n'êtes pas flexible voilà
alors ça va on laisse tomber ça pour
voir
l'allemagne
faut pas oublier la france sont deux
locomotives de l'intégration européenne
les relations avec ces pays
mais pas seulement avec ces deux pays
l'italie ou l'autriche ont la grèce ou
l'espagne sont privilégiés ça marche
très bien et on a beaucoup de registres
et beaucoup de percer dans plusieurs
domaines de notre coopération
l'allemagne c'est notre partenaire
économique et financier numéro un dans
le monde à cause de ça je pense que
vraiment l'allemagne certains des pays
qui nous comprend mieux
que certains
partenaires allemands au sein de l'union
européenne
certains voisins allemands surtout à
l'est de l'or le sommet de samara a été
un échec pour l'europe des 27 mais aussi
pour la russie près c'est d'apaiser les
relations par un accord global
économique et stratégique indispensable
à la stabilité de son économie
les ressources énergétiques sont les
seuls atouts qui lui permettent de
garder son rang et de renforcer sa
position dans le monde en europe comme
en asie
actuel pour les russes chaque génération
cherche à trouver sa réponse à cette
question nous sommes au point où nous
sommes les habitants
avec qui aller dans le futur alors je
pense que
pour nous le plus important c'est garder
le balance balance des intérêts et à
l'est et à l'ouest de la russie cette
prime en seconde à ce qu'il faut avoir
la ceinture autour de la russie la
ceinture des pays
amicaux pour la russie indépendamment de
leur présence en europe et en asie pour
réaliser ce délicate équilibres
géostratégiques
la kz2 gravité de la russie se recentre
vers l'est la russie de vladimir poutine
bascule peu à peu vers l'asie
la chine dont la croissance économique a
un besoin crucial de nouvelles
ressources énergétiques gaz et pétrole
boitant la russie un fournisseur naturel
mais la méfiance et la rivalité ont
toujours existé entre le pays le plus
vaste du monde la russie est le pays le
plus peuplé du monde la chine
après la lune de miel des années 50 les
relations entre les deux pays se sont
détériorées suite à l'abandon du modèle
soviétique par les dirigeants pékin les
oppositions croissantes ont entraîné des
crise particulièrement grave dans les
années 60 presque une guerre une rupture
sur le plan des visions diplomatiques
des deux géants du bloc socialiste
dix ans après la chute de l'union
soviétique
le traité d'amitié et de bon voisinage
signé en 2001 a permis d'inaugurer de
nouvelles relations
aujourd'hui la russie et la chine
travaille main dans la main dans une
structure créée en 2001 l'organisation
de coopération de shanghai ocs qui
regroupe six pays eurasiatique la russie
la chine mais également le kazakhstan la
kirghizie le tadjikistan et
l'ouzbékistan
je vous prie de bien vouloir venir
rencontrer le secrétaire général
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai
monsieur bolat un orgue à liège entre et
s'il vous plaît c'est un haut diplomate
du kazakhstan qui est à la tête du
secrétariat général bolat nurgaliev a
longtemps été l'ambassadeur du
kazakhstan aux états unis
la connaissance de ce pays va lui servir
pour beaucoup l'eau csa pour objectif
implicite de faire reculer l'influencé
des états unis dans la région
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai s'est formée à partir du g5 de
shanghai qui a été fondé en 1996 1997 je
suis d'une part à la signature des
conventions que le kazakhstan le
kirghizstan la russie et le tadjikistan
et d'autre part de la chine
cette coopération porte en fait sur le
renforcement de la confiance dans le
domaine militaire et la réduction des
forces armées le long des frontières de
l'eau cs permet à la russie de sécuriser
ses frontières avec des pays désormais
amis
mais aussi de faire bloc face à l'otan
en août 2007 le cs montre ses muscles en
organisant des grandes manoeuvres des
exercices militaires intitulé émission
pour la paix 2007 regroupe six mille
cinq cents soldats des diverses pays
membres dans le nord ouest de la chine
un événement majeur en asie pratiquement
passée inaperçue en occident pourtant
c'est à l'occasion de cette rencontre au
sommet des six chefs d'état de l'eau
c'est est ce
que le président russe va annoncer la
reprise des vols des bombardiers
stratégiques russes interrompu depuis
1992 un message clair directement
adressée à l'otan
aujourd'hui le 17 août à minuit
6014 bombardiers stratégiques ont
décollé
mais aussi des avions d'accompagnement
et des avions ravitailleurs
ils sont partis de cet aérodrome de
différentes régions de la fédération de
russie iso pratique
c'est grâce à la contribution de
l'organisation dans la sauvegarde de la
stabilité dans la zone sous sa
responsabilité
que son autorité est devenue importante
le cs est une alliance militaire mais
pas seulement
depuis 2005 quatre pays de la région ont
rejoint l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai en qualité de membre
observateur
l'affluence de l'ocr s'étend désormais à
la mongolie à l'inde au pakistan et à
l'iran
presque un continent qui rassemble des
pays riches en ressources énergétiques
et des pays qui en manquent cruellement
pour assurer leur développement
nous considérons que le rôle potentiel
des pays de l'organisation de
coopération de shanghai dans le maintien
de la sécurité énergétique globale est
considérable
logiciels ssrs cage à l'échelle mondiale
nos réserves énergétiques réunis
représentent
9 des 20 % du pétrole
gagne 38 % du gaz
40% du charbon
et plus de 50 % de l'uranium
oui
dans le cadre de l'osce et s
nous cherchons à instaurer un mécanisme
de coordination efficace
et ils
ont ce but aura lieu dans les prochains
mois à moscou
la première rencontre des ministres
et des chefs des départements issus du
complexe énergétique
des représentants de chacun des six pays
membres
à moscou seront discutées les questions
des stratégies énergétiques
et notamment la création du club
énergétiques de l'eau ces actifs courbe
chose
ce nouveau club énergétique au coeur de
l'asie va permettre à la russie et à
gazprom de trouver de nouveaux débouchés
à sa production de gaz et de pétrole
d'exploiter de nouveaux gisements de
réaliser de nouveaux investissements
mon pas très bons skieurs que toi vous
croisez besoin de la chine en gaz sont
évidents
l'économie de ce pays est en croissance
constante
la demande de ressources énergétiques
grandi
les livraisons de gaz russe en chine
sont une évidence aussi banal que le
lever et le coucher du soleil
cependant ce n'est absolument pas une
raison pour laquelle les consommateurs
européens doivent s'inquiéter
il est impossible de détourner les
courants de gaz
comme on l'écrit parfois dans les
journaux aucune base
nous apprenons nous on ne peut pas
tourner la soupape ici à moscou et
dirigé le gaz non pas à vienne ou à
paris mais à pékin ou à shanghai
[Musique]
le gaz et le pétrole qui sera fourni à
la chine proviendra de l'est de la
russie et du kazakhstan
au moment où gazprom devra faire des
investissements pour augmenter son
réseau il devra arbitrer entre son
marché asiatique et le marché européen
réguler le marché du gaz savoir où
doivent être concentrés des
investissements c'est l'une des
priorités de gazprom
chaque année est organisé le forum
international des pays exportateurs de
gaz en 2007 il a eu lieu au mois d'avril
au qatar petit pays du golfe
membre de l'opep est classé au troisième
rang mondial pour ses réserves de gaz
naturel
trois pays la russie l'iran et le qatar
contrôle près de 56 % des réserves
mondiales et 27 % de la production
de par sa position géographique le qatar
s'est naturellement tournée vers
l'exploitation du gaz sous forme
liquéfiée exportable par navire à
travers le monde
l'édition 2007 du forum a été observé de
très près par les américains et les
européens
car une nouvelle idée semble voir le
jour dans les discours entre les pays
exportateurs de gaz
une idée défendue par les russes présent
forum
mais qui a été lancé deux mois plus tôt
par vladimir poutine
le 1er février lors de sa traditionnelle
conférence de presse annuelle le
président de la fédération de russie a
fait sensation
gazeau à pitre créer une opep du gaz est
une idée très intéressante non
on va y réfléchir
ça doivent mais dans un premier temps
nous nous mettons d'accord avec les
spécialistes iraniens
mi-octobre douguine nos partenaires
iraniens
cantons ainsi qu'avec d'autres pays qui
sont des acteurs majeurs de la
production d'hydrocarbures
et spécialement de gaz
nous essayons déjà de coordonner nos
actions sur les marchés
des pays en développement et nous
continuerons à le faire dans le futur
nous n'envisageons pas de créer un
cartel
mais de coordonner nos activités et mais
je pense que c'est la bonne chose à
faire pour garder pour objectif
principal imad yole approvisionnement
fiable et sécurisée de nos clients
au forum les russes sont poursuivis par
les caméras à commencer par alexeï
miller le patron de gazprom mais fidèle
à sa réputation il ne dira rien devant
les caméras mais au forum l'idée d'une
opep du gaz fait son chemin
[Musique]
maintenant l'école et ma blague
ce sont les mêmes principes que ceux de
l'aubaine lorsque nous avons créé nous
avions des discussions comme celle ci
alors non ce n'est pas fait comme on
peut quelqu'un en particulier contre les
consommateurs et que ne ce n'est pas ça
le marché du gaz est un marché différent
de celui du pétrole c'est un marché plus
mature
nous pensons que nous pouvons mettre au
point un type de coordination pour une
politique d'exportation commune mais
aussi pour le prix
harcelé par la presse le ministre
iranien la création d'une opep du gaz
dans laquelle les iraniens tiendrait un
rôle important inquiète les occidentaux
pourquoi devrait-il y avoir une chose
pareille il y a des besoins du côté des
consommateurs et aussi du côté des
producteurs donc le gaz doivent circuler
je ne vois pas pourquoi il y aurait ce
genre d'inquiétude je ne comprends
vraiment pas adlène de 5
mais celui dont on attend le plus la
déclaration c'est viktor khristenko
ministre russe de l'énergie
en premier lieu tous les acteurs
soutiennent activement
l'importance de l'organisation et du
fonctionnement du forum des pays
exportateurs de gaz
en deuxième lieu pour ce qui est de la
suite du travail du forum les
participants se sont mis d'accord sur
une série de sujets d'actualité ayant un
impact sur l'élargissement de ce genre
de coopération
il s'agit de sujets tels que
l'établissement des prix dans
l'industrie gazière
l'infrastructure de l'industrie gazière
les relations avec les consommateurs
une décision a été prise donnant
naissance au comité de coordination de
haut niveau qui sera chargé d'effectuer
le travail nécessaire pour la résolution
de ces questions tout au long de cette
année
comment expliquez vous la réaction
quelque peu exaspéré à l'égard de ce
forum en europe et aux états unis
et bien tout d'abord on peut l'expliquer
par des tensions occasionnelles qui
marque le dialogue énergétique à torres
lancé par le g8 hier
je vous remercie suite à ce forum la
chambre des représentants des états unis
a adopté un projet de loi visant à
contrecarrer la création d'une opep du
gaz
l'introduction du projet précise
les efforts déployés en matière de
création d'un cartel en vue de fixer des
prix arbitrairement et hors marché à des
fins de pressions politiques sont
considérés par les états unis comme une
démarche inamicale menaçant la sécurité
des états unis et du monde entier
[Musique]
l'expérience
30 gazprom est l'un des plus grands
exportateurs de gaz et ce forum nous
offre un auditoire où nos interlocuteurs
ne sont pas tant des concurrents que des
acteurs qui ont une idée précise de ce
que nous faisons de la nature de notre
business et avec qui nous avons échangé
étant donné qu'à l'heure actuelle dans
le monde qui la concurrence pour l'accès
aux ressources énergétiques augmentent
les acteurs concernés devront coordonner
nos actions et nos projets
d'investissement
[Musique]
un groupe de travail de haut niveau sera
créé il prendra en charge la préparation
de l'ordre du jour de la prochaine
réunion
nous espérons qu'elle aura lieu à moscou
et que nous pourrons accueillir les
participants de la prochaine rencontre
sur les terres d'origine du gaz russe
au forum nous avons croisé plusieurs
fois le numéro un de gazprom alexeï
miller se rendant d'un rendez vous
discrets à un autre rendez vous discrets
avec les producteurs de gaz du monde
entier ce jour là
comme toujours il a refusé de répondre à
nos questions
quinze ans seulement se sont écoulés
depuis la chute de l'urss et du point de
vue historique c'est un laps de temps
très court quand on sait tous ce qui
s'est passé pendant cette période oui
une russie puissante ne plaît pas
forcément à tout le monde mais je pense
que c'est dans l'intérêt du monde entier
d'avoir une russie forte plutôt qu'une
russie faible tout comme un gazprom
solide est un avantage pour nos clients
comme pour le monde entier milov sort
décembre 2007 à trois mois des élections
le président poutine désigne son dauphin
dimitri medvedev vice premier ministre
mais aussi le président du conseil
d'administration de gazprom
depuis 17 ans est l'homme de confiance
de vladimir poutine pour beaucoup sa
nomination à gazprom en 2005 et l
assurance pour la dîme utile de
contrôler le géant gazier candidat du
kremlin l'élection de dimitri medvedev
en mars 2008 est assurée pour le